لا نستطيع ان نستقبل هذا الكم الهائل من
الاصابات نحن مستشفى في الاساس للنساء
والولاده والاطفال اضطررنا ان نستقبل
الالاف من الاصابات والمئات من الشهداء
عدد طواقمنا صغير جدا جدا نحن نعمل بقيمه
10% فقط من الطواقم الطبيه والان الطواقم
اجهدت بشكل كامل استطعنا ان نجري ما
نستطيع ان نجريه من العمليات لانقاذ
الحياه هناك العشرات من الحالات التي
تحتاج الى تدخل جراحي ولا نستطيع ان نفعل
لها شيئا في لدينا اصابات تنزف حتى الموت
لا نستطيع ايقاف النزيف بالوسائل الاسعاف
الاولي تحتاج الى تدخل جراحي الاطباء وال
والممرضون استنفذت طاقاتهم لا نستطيع تحمل
هذا الكم الهائل خاصه مع نفاز الوقود كنا
لدينا خطه لنوفر
الوقود المولد الرئيسي يعمل فقط ثلاثه
اربع ساعات في اليوم الان يعمل 14 و15
ساعه مما ادى الى نفاس كميه الوقود
المتوفره لدينا على فجر الغد لن يكون هناك
اي قطره للوقود فبالتالي لن نستطيع ان
نجري اي عمليات ولن نستطيع ان نقوم
بالولادات